there have been a lot of rumors about
Megan and what she's really like behind
the scenes of course she is an actress
and when you see her in public that
megawatt smile she is the consummate
professional and this reputation for
being difficult was linked to an
unusually high turnover of staff at the
palace Megan gets up early five o'clock
in the morning oftentimes gets on the
treadmill or whatever and starts texting
her team members about things for that
day probably in her mind she's just kind
of getting her day set up but royal
staff members were certainly not
expecting or happy to start getting a
barrage of text messaged instructions
starting at 5:30 every morning and took
great umbrage and offense at that but I
would just say these celebrities do that
so for her I think she was a bit shocked
certainly that within the royal family
there's a whole different protocol when
it comes to speaking to staff
Megan's approach to things have been
different and has it ruffled some
feathers yes it has
so the tabloids have coined this name
for Megan the difficult Duchess which I
don't think is fair and I'll tell you
why there's nothing wrong with being a
woman who knows what she wants the fact
that she is a feminist she's somebody
who's known for really speaking up for
what she believes in people don't like
that and it comes not just from a place
of jealousy but also from a place of
sexism one thing I think Americans don't
understand is how vilified Megan has
actually been in the British press she
cannot put a foot right how has she
responded well for the most part
following that very famous royal rule
never complain never explain and that is
what the Royals do
[Music]